[Applause]
it's the friendship we never knew we
needed selena gomez and real housewives
of new york star luanne de la sept
i am so excited it all started when the
56 year old bravo liberty posted this
tick tock last week congratulating
selena gomez on her new hulu show only
murders in the building
[Music]
yep that's the reality star lip syncing
to a remix of selena's song love you
like a love song
[Music]
a follower left a comment on the video
throwing some subtle shade at luanne
writing quote i don't know if she's
gonna see this babe
i love it well that's when luanne
delivered an epic clapback responding to
the comment with a video of selena
dancing and singing to her song felin
giovanni
[Laughter]
[Applause]
she captioned the clip quote even selena
gomez loves giovanni and that's what we
call a mic drop it was so much fun but
the countess isn't the only one slaying
on tick tock selena has been crushing it
too we hope everybody enjoys it over the
weekend she danced with her little
sister gracie to lizzo and cardi b's
rumors and get this lizzo dueted the
video on stage while performing at the
global citizen live benefit concert
earlier this month selena and gracie did
a little choreography to the viral linda
and heather trend
[Music]
and last month she shared this hilarious
clip of her grandpa in the gym
[Music]
yeah his fitness routine had her and us
totally shook she captioned the post
quote my 73 year old grandfather had to
prove a point
[Music]
now we can only hope selena responds to
luanne's tick tock or better yet a duet
[Applause]